like so many other parts of the world
this area nowadays called the Islamic
Republic of Iran has gone by many names
by far the most famous of these names is
Persia this name actually comes from a
misunderstanding
in which the administrative region of
the Achaemenid Empire Persis or pass was
mistaken for the name of the entire
empire they shouldn't be too surprising
given at those who gave them this name
often named their empires in the same
way also in case you're wondering this
was also where the name for the Iranian
language Farsi comes from now Persia
wasn't the name that the people of the
Persian Empire used to describe it and
they often used area Iran or a rancher
to refer to it which means of the Aryans
the name given to the people who lived
there and not you know those other guys
ancient Iran isn't the same as the
modern nation of Iran and has been a
name used by many peoples from Syria to
Afghanistan to describe the area that
they lived in now native names for a
nation aren't often the ones used by
outsiders just a skosh land or junk war
unlike Germany or China the name for
Iran has changed in by formal
correspondence and everyday
communication so when did this change
occur when did the majority of people
start calling Persia Iran well the
change was a fairly recent one coming
about in 1935 when the Shah of Iran Reza
Shah demanded that everyone stopped
calling at Persia and start calling it
well Iran Reza Shah was a nationalist in
the sense that he wanted to make Iran a
more unified centralized state something
made harder by the fact that everyone
outside the nation called it in its
people by the wrong name as such Reza
Shah whilst at the League of Nations
formally asked all of the nations to
refer to his kingdom as Iran and that
continuing to call it Persia would be
seen as disrespectful
now some countries like the United
States in Nazi Germany were pretty quick
at taking on these changes whereas
others were not so quick and by others I
mean pretty much exclusively the United
Kingdom formally there were some changes
at this point such as the anglo-persian
oil company being renamed to the
anglo-iranian oil company however at the
highest levels that the British
government it was still known as Persia
because old habits and all that British
governors and bureaucrats often mr.
Quran for simply being a misspelling or
variation of Iraq and so correspondents
started to get mixed up when Reza Shahs
successor Mohammad Reza Shah came to
London he was originally going to be
given the title of Shah of Iran except
that the serving British Prime Minister
Winston Churchill didn't like Iran's new
name and so demanded that it be changed
which it was much to the annoyance of
many Iranian diplomats as for Mohammad
a Shah himself he didn't really care and
said both names were perfectly
acceptable that said momentum was on
Iran's side in by the mid-1970s the name
change it finely filtered down to all
countries and the British government was
successfully referring to Iran as Iran
and so afterwards Persia would forever
after lose its contemporary meaning and
would only be attached to an empire that
hadn't existed for roughly 1400 years I
hope you enjoyed this episode and thank
you for watching me thanks to my patreon
supporters whom you can see on screen
now plus with an extra special thanks to
James Bissonnette Danny Maloney coolin
Castleman party boy Co Rob Waterhouse Mo
Aaron the white Michael Reynolds Chris
wicker Gustav Swan Ashwin Emperor Gareth
Turner David Silverman spinning three
plates
Maggie packs Kowski Christian check a
Spencer Lightfoot
Winston K word Anthony Beckett Kelly
moneymaker
Robert Wetzel Lexi Schwinn Skye Chappell
and Ike